has a joke ever hurt your feelings oh
yeah really yeah why that's why they're
all anymore everything I was like I get
it man I don't want it I like jokes
going that way I don't want him this way
why are people still talking about that
was that a big deal at the time it was a
big deal time because to have a huge SNL
guy call me at work and lay me the fuck
out like unbelievably I was like this
and Chris Rock was on the other phone
going he wants to get away from me just
to salvage his relationship with Eddie
he's don't push me with it so you did a
joke on SNL making fun of Eddie and then
he called you are you guys fine now I
saw him last night really we are fine
yeah finally he didn't like it laid me
out and I loved him
well yeah but I did a joke about me and
like it and you know people go oh you
know his fur specially shitting on mr. t
like everybody but I couldn't get that
in through the screams I was more like
in shock and I wasn't gonna talk back to
him I was just I took it I took it I
said I'm sorry and I didn't mean for
like that I think you're fuckin great
fuck you fuck you and then not me he
said then ya hung up so then it was this
lifelong problem and he wouldn't do SNL
anymore he wouldn't come on SNL he
wouldn't go to read and so when he
hosted he said I'm gonna drop this thing
I have about Spade I'm gonna drop it and
I'm gonna forget about it and I'm gonna
host and I'm and it's all behind me and
it took that long Wow and so it was uh
but but you know it sort of affected me
in a weird way because people always
knew about in Rock every couple years
ago I saw Eddie this weekend still hates
you and I'd go goddamn I just felt bad
because he had to hear my name cuz
they'd bring it up interviews ago you
still mad it was like I just didn't like
it I just didn't like what happened I
was mad at him I was mad at Loren and
it's nice that it's sort of over now any
Indian have to hear my fucking name of
my one stupid joke along there we go so
but truth is I don't like Joe oh I did
SNL when I left they did a bit about me
three shows after I left I was like god
damn
but that's just the way it is you know
our show does it and I make fun of
myself so whatever